welcome to this video this is finally
the first part of episode of the viewer
games reviewed yes I requested that you
sent me
games of years that I will review on
video yeah and this is the first one how
did I select the game pretty simple
method I just took the first one that
that was sent to me in very early
January I think so it was just the first
game in the inbox with them with this
subject and it is an interesting game it
was played between two players that want
to remain anonymous
I left that let's say optionally you
could give your name or not in this case
the white player the white player was
the one who sent in the game he wanted
to stay anonymous yeah no problem with
that I totally understand what is useful
though to know the ratings this was a
tournament game and the white player
wants to sue is 1500 rate and this is
the viewer of the channel and the black
player is slightly stronger with 1650
rating now it's useful to know those
ratings simply to put things in
perspective because you can cannot let's
say expect a completely perfect play
from players of that level you have to
judge the moves a little bit in in
relation to to their ratings and their
experience levels so let's start this
game and see what happened white went c4
by the way I will of course also look at
the black player even if we mostly want
to look at what our viewer here has done
and he wants some feedback obviously on
his play which I will give but there
also of course will have a look what
black did and try to evaluate what
happened so see for the English opening
not quite clear there might be
transpositions - - quite a lot
but relatively quickly after Knight f6
g3 c5 we come to something that really
can only be called the English it is the
symmetrical English with c4 c5 yeah
Bishop g2 and g6 a 93 Bishop g7 so all
very very logical right now plate Knight
f3 which is of course a perfectly normal
move and that might be that I have
played it myself and this this type of
position when I was playing c4 g3 a
little bit more frequently however this
move in relation or let's say if you
look at what happens later I'm not so
sure that this fits so well I probably
will come to this point later and then
explain what what I mean black now
castled White Castle and knight c6 so we
have a completely symmetrical position
those positions look deceptively simple
but they aren't because at one point is
the symmetry will be yeah will be broken
and there will be something happening
that that gives live injects life into
the position here white now has a very
fundamental choice
he can play d4 I can avoid the smooth
this is the the basic question that he
needs to answer now that the people on
who examined is opening theoretically
and years of practice have actually
pretty much proved that what should play
d4 in general I can say that it is my
opinion and I think I'm mostly shared by
AM by
by other players that in those kind of
situations c4 c5 that symmetrical
English the player who plays d4 d5 we
will see that white is actually playing
d3 instead of D for the player who is
going in for this break with the deform
it's normally the one trying to gain the
initiative and this is in general I
think what we should try to do try to
fight for the initiative with black
playing d5 is a little bit more
difficult because of the tempo down it
is only possible in some specific
situations or actually really early for
example if we go back here yeah here
black could play d5 if he wants the the
same pawn break that white head-on move
I think it's number 7 right yeah blue 7
yeah black could have done that yeah
however here there is some specific
there are some specific circumstances
here for example white um has this
pressure on d5 so black actually should
retreat the knight now which is not very
desirable you had to move the knight all
of the time but you have gotten your
break in in the actual game if we look
at this d3 was played but if now d40x
take takes takes a it's not this big
pressure on d4 so why does not force to
move the knight in fact the main
theoretical continuation here is the
capture and then black plays d6 and in
this position white normally is believed
to enjoy very slight advantage nothing
special but it is a nice position mostly
based on the fact that this bishop is
having a very nice diagonal some
pressure on this pawn on b7 it wise has
a little bit more space oftentimes also
connected with the idea to put a knight
on d5 later if not in the next two or
three moves
usually you should go deform and also in
other situations if you don't play
deform you have very little left in
terms of constructive play what is right
going to do it the position at the
moment is completely closed and you have
to get in some sort of break with the
pawns to open up files yeah of course I
mean you can do a nothing move a groupie
one or something but it is really having
no particular idea you either play for
default or now we come to the second
plan that right may go for you can play
for a three and before breaking on the
queenside this is actually what the
white player tries to do in this game
however if you want to do that yeah
follow this idea with a three before you
can actually say okay then it might be
an idea to start right here a three look
B one before and even no don't don't
develop the night or at all to f3
because here we have the diagonal open
for a longer time and the queenside
plane is hitting much quicker what gets
in a3 before in in much quicker way this
is an idea also one additional benefit
of this is that you have very nice
control over D 585 is just blundering
upon so black cannot do that if Knight
f3 what the player what why did actually
here black had the opportunity if he
wanted to play d5 himself which is not
leading to an advantage but it's it's
it's the ambitious move that very often
you you want to prevent yeah okay white
him played d3 which is kind of a little
bit indecisive this move what is white
actually going to do he probably only
wanted to play the next move Bishop d2
sort of yeah put the pieces out but what
it does not do it doesn't serve a
particular purpose white is not really
playing very actively
and following a plan like this a three
before plan or d4 before is what I like
most but d3 I mean it's not a mistake
it's just not very it's not a very
purposeful move yeah black now played
the move rook b8 so what he's doing is
it's the same idea he wants to play a
six and b5 this is possible not a not a
bad move you know the alternative was
you can guess d5 yeah just switching
sides let's say black is now the one
who's going in for this break and
probably after takes takes um we have a
position now where white will take for
example Queen takes and now now it's a
very interesting moment and this is a
completely theoretical position um
played many times it's important to
understand that from a structural point
of view this is something that is
relatively comfortable for black yeah he
has the diagonal yeah I remember what I
what we looked at earlier yeah the same
deform and takes takes this is the same
thing after d3 d5 takes takes takes
takes it's the same thing but why does
the tempo up why does it move up and in
fact this extra tempo is something that
white can use with Bishop III intending
this discovery 94 this is actually a
relatively sharp line I mean yeah it's
not as sharp as the dragon or whatever
but there are some tech tactics going on
and very often this leads to to a
quality d5 is is a good move that black
can play but it is important really that
white head plays actively if he plays
some lame moves yeah I don't know a3 or
whatever something lame then black will
take over the initiative yeah d5 was the
principle alternative route b8 it's not
bad but I like I like to play in the
center with d5
yeah Bishop d2 this is this is a move
that it's not doing very much
he wants to potentially connect rooks
and possibly camera c3 but when it is
not doing is it's not addressing what
black wants to do black will play a six
b5 and white has to do something about
it and Bishop d2 is not reacting to the
plan as we will see what wide can do he
can basically do the same like is doing
like this rook b1 a 6 a 3 B 5 T stakes
and now white is just ready to play
before and now we will get him a
completely symmetrical position which is
kind of a boring result of this but this
is due to the fact that white played the
somewhat yeah yeah not very active move
d3 yeah we're here go d4 you can fight
for an advantage but here you are just
staying and this is a pretty dull
position really it's totally symmetrical
and probably not much will happen but
this is what white has to do is he's
reduced to that led same he went Bishop
d2 instead and now we see black playing
a6
Luke b1 was played and now um now black
plays a very mysterious move black
actually has everything set up for the
move b5 and to my surprise he's not
playing it yeah
if he plays b5 now black is just a
little bit more comfortable the problem
is you're too late with your a3 before
counter plan and white now is an it's in
a bit of a yeah in the spot of bother
what is he going to do he is definitely
too late for that
as before hits and this is very very
awkward because you can do something
like that but yeah you're basically
admitting that you just eternally verse
and
at least yeah nothing dramatic but yeah
we have a week B to pawn black has a one
Island pawn structure which is always
very nice it's a very compact setup and
why it has two islands yeah with this
isolated B to pawn so you're too late
with your counter plane and it's
questionable if you really should take
on me five it's probably better to yeah
then I'll stay passive yeah but you see
what is already a little bit on the
defensive which is the reason or which
is some the the reason is that he played
this d3 Bishop d2 which is kind of
passive but mysteriously black didn't
play b5 he played the move rook e8 which
is I cannot really explain it
I don't don't know what what the idea is
now but this is a something that is seen
quite often in in games of of that level
that one side is actually picking up a
plan or starting with a plan but it's
not really um yeah realizing it very
purposefully the tempo lost here and
there or some wrinkle is played that
it's not necessary here the
straightforward move beehive which is
really fitting perfectly to the move
some that would play before it's just
leading to a good game for black but
well Ruby ater it it simply does not
relate to the form of moves and well
this is sometimes happening in in those
games they start with them a decent plan
but then somehow it is not completely
realized to the fullest so it's not very
principal to the place of times rook e8
yeah here white should take the chance
to play a3 relief yeah so simply to be
ready with this counter play with before
but why didn't do that he played Queen
c1 and this is kind of fitting to the
policy that will seen before this is
passive there's this no there is no
active
connected with the move the only idea
that I can spot is Bishop to h6 but this
is not helping very much as black will
play Bishop to h8 and keep the bishop or
he can also just allow the trade which
is not terrible
why does losing quite quite some time
with this with this action cm yeah the
problem is if you want to play for an
advantage here with white what can you
do there are pawn breaks there's piece
play with piece play in such a very
close position you get nowhere
you cannot let's say yeah concentrate
your pieces on the King side and start
an attack or on the Queen side sometimes
in some positions this is possible it's
all about activating pieces you are
putting them or concentrating them on
side of the board this is not happening
here here it's all about pawn breaks and
white is not going for any palm break he
really should go a3 and if it's only to
counter blacks play but you never know
maybe rook e8 was the start of something
totally different and maybe a black
plays I don't know ecigs
on hard to guess and then you get before
and and all of a sudden you're kind of
in the game so you should play with one
one plan and really follow it through
especially if it's about palm breaks
because those are time crucial yeah you
cannot just yeah linger around all the
time and then play the break later it
might not be possible later
so Quincy one and now yeah again black
should just play b5 which he didn't he
didn't play b5 what he did is play d5
yeah so he mixed plans yeah he maybe you
or felt that there are those ideas like
a6 b5 Rock b8 Queen side play and
there's d5 but what he did is he mixed
it mixed it up completely I he started
with the Queen side play with those free
with this with these moves rook being an
a6 but didn't didn't play it didn't play
b5 and now he switches back to a
five plan yeah so this is not very yeah
it's not a very consequent way to play
and you should yeah who says a has to
say beer should follow up on your idea
which does not mean you should follow
every idea blindly if you start an idea
yeah they're just kind of a maneuver
that takes three four or five moves and
then after move to you see a while
that's not going to work okay
you should just bite the bullet and well
let's see to limit the damage but this
is not the case here it's not that there
was ideas with a six rook b8 were
nonsense black could just play b5 but
he's going back to the d5 idea as it
turns out this movie is a really big
mistake CD 5 mm 95 and now white played
to move 83 yeah this kind of fits to
what happened earlier white is not
really thinking it seems in terms of
active play he's playing a kind of move
that belongs in the position you know
very often you go a3 to play before okay
but it's always very important to think
about positions also in very concrete
terms chess is a very concrete game
every concrete threat idea tactic it
totally over rules any strategic
consideration yeah you can be positioned
as nice as you want if there's a tactic
and he mates you it doesn't help you
that you have a great night somewhere or
things like that here white with very
concrete play could have gotten an
excellent position yeah and the thing is
what he could do is he could take on d5
which is a move that has to be
calculated really like a tactic in any
case because it is totally forced after
Knight takes like has to take with the
Queen and this is something that Wright
has to calculate in any case also
because the Queen is now right
in the diagonal of the bishop so it's
always technically somewhat dubious that
this kind of situation you have to check
those discoveries by the night yeah but
you start to calculate discoveries by
the knight on f3 you will come to the
conclusion that at the moment they don't
really add up to much move like 95 is
kind of pointless yeah black can even
take on a 2m but what we need is we need
a better discovery we need a good square
to go to with the night and when you
look at the position you probably would
spot the move Bishop to f4 and this is a
strong move it is a temple move that's
very important we use the position of
the rook note that this rook position
also does not fit totally it does not
fit in with this d5 break yes bishop FR
f is coming with the tempo this is a
very very problematic move now black has
to react to this attack on the rook and
after he has reacted White has a big
discovery by the knight
the big problem is after UK 8 White has
95 and all of a sudden ya notice like a
coid spring how White's position has
become active black really ran into this
with his mistimed d5 break yeah here
black is in big trouble
the queen is attacked if you grab on a 2
this is directly losing an exchange on
top yeah so that's a complete loss Black
has to go back and after that white can
take here and now this is a this is a
fantastic position for my idea the white
structure is completely completely sound
there is no weakness whatsoever
and black has those yeah immensely weak
doubled pawns important is being precise
in this position white is better
but you should make sure that you cash
in in the in the best possible way it's
important to see that you will win the
c5 pawn anyway
black has absolutely no way to save that
when you see that it will be attacked
with Bishop to e3 and possibly yeah
later with with some heavy piece
carrying on the C Farouk c1 or something
the pawn will drop so what we need to do
is we just have to kill the counter play
only - for example the fire plays a move
like rook e1 Bishop a three years is
similar but move like this it covers
this possible counter play and if white
gets time like b3 Queen c2 rook c1
Bishop b3 he will pick up the pawn in a
very convenient way and have a fantastic
endgame with a pawn and still a bad
structure it's not really necessary at
this point to start calculating stuff
yeah like can you take here yeah maybe
you can but now two pawns are hanging
yeah it's it's kind of complicated it's
not necessary with a sound move like
this you're probably winning without any
hassle note that black still cannot take
because this picks up the exchange yeah
it's very important to understand that
this line is totally forced black also
cannot do here and because this is even
losing more material so the mistake that
the white player made here the the
viewer was that he didn't think of this
position in concrete terms he really
should start to calculate here and also
start to yeah think about some some
active moves yeah white cannot just a3
is kind of okay I'm doing nothing what
are you doing you want to be active and
then play and play through sweat through
some threatening moves and with this you
can all of a sudden grab the initiative
and get a really really nice position
it's really about thinking about the
forcing moves taking Bishop f4 this is
forcing it's very forcing chess this
rook is attacked and black
to react so this was a big opportunity
that the white player missed with this
e3 move yeah now black actually should
take on c3 and get rid of this somewhat
unstable Knight position of the 45
he played however he 5 you know II 5
again it's White's move what should he
play he took on d5 that's correct
and here yeah he white played the move
Bishop c3 and this is is a pattern
that's forming in this game what white
is not doing he's not thinking in
concrete in concrete moves and threats
Bishop c3 is a kind of move okay I'll do
that
what are you doing it's not threatening
anything black now has okay in a
threatening 94 let's say yeah but black
black will remove the Queen and did he
do that
26 right yeah even remove the Queen and
then there is nothing happening really
instead if you look at this what you
need to be aware of is always this
situation there are tactics this is
concrete moves now Knight g5 and those
kind of moves are possible what what
must do is if he needs to find good
discoveries and also what is very
important might has to be aware that all
of a sudden the Queen position on c1
does have some point the Queen is
putting some pressure on a vulnerable
pawn the pawn is not protected
this means that white actually has two
good moves IAM he could have played
Bishop III which is strong
instead of Bishop c3 the difference is
now we are taking this pawn how is black
even defending that it's not easy
a move like b6 there's always this idea
but that's a funny reply has to be
considered so white has to make sure
that his circumspect here 94
actually running into big trouble but
White has another tactic here after b6 I
can take here and just win upon ya you
have to spot the weaknesses in the
opponent's positions here the weaknesses
are the somewhat shaky position of the
Queen
this is lending to tactics you know then
important the c5 pawn is a liability the
combination of the two factors actually
lead to white being in a very good shape
here Bishop b3 would have led to an
advantage on Knight g5 also this is in
fact a very concrete line when you look
at it the queen is attacked and well if
it knows we're probably just taking c5
have to be has to be checked in an era
concrete case after Queen d8 for example
Queens c5 is not 100% clear after 94
because there are some counter threats
all of a sudden but White has to move
Queen c4 but ok look at this this is
active yeah this is active play White
has threats here and all of a sudden he
has gained the initiative so this is
what he needed to do 95 or Bishop e3 I
don't know what I like better it's it's
both um pretty convincing the ship c3 is
too threatening 94 but black can react
to that pretty easily and now again
White is sitting with a somewhat passive
structure he played Queen d2
in 94 yeah that's very often a key idea
you put the night in the middle of the
board and well it moves III leads to
weaknesses yeah like if you look at this
check here the pawn is somewhat
vulnerable on d3 and if white takes well
here it is not not really possible but I
mean here this is kind of embarrassing
but in any case if you take it will be
replaced by a strong pawn that also
limits white suppose
abilities what he did is right actually
played before getting some play on the
queenside and I'm glad that he played
them played active active move now yeah
you don't you cannot sit around all the
time you have to do something active
black played b5 and takes takes b5 is
this is a bit questionable but it takes
a very precise play to prove that here
the white player our viewer he played
Knight takes d4 no which is the kind of
obvious move that comes to mind in fact
here he could have played he could have
played stronger but it's that's not easy
to see I mean really realistically it's
not easy to see the move Roxy one is
quite strong here the point is that
black cannot really conveniently take on
a3 but as I mentioned it's not so easy
to see if black takes him the problem is
that if you think of this all of the
sudden the white bishops are getting a
very very active and black has a hard
time to keep his rookie you know one of
the rooks actually and this is a TechEd
and there's also this coming plus the
queen is offside which means that Queen
a3 is not really great black has to do
something like let's say capture jack
then maybe retreat or Bishop d7 maybe
Bishop d7 as possible yeah here white is
in fact all of a sudden in quite good
shape because of the activity with Rupe
c1 it but this is well that wasn't easy
to see ready but why did is he took and
played Bishop before that's okay
Queeny five
and rupee - yeah well he too was
attacked so this does make makes sense
yeah
this position is probably about equal
there is some there is some some some
asymmetry here with a six and B 5 yeah
Black has chances to maybe get a
passport but not easy because White has
a very reliable reliable and locate here
with the bishop on on d4 on before and
it's not easy for black to to make some
headway here
yeah the bishop is also covering this
weekend square so what is nicely
positioned for defense which is not
distant mini is worse it's just like it
balances out each other white also has
some ideas on the see if I we would see
that rook b2 less mentioned was the last
move Bishop d7 yeah trading this often
this is useful and right took take the C
file Queen six and route BC to that data
like everything is nice white has taken
the C file and at the same time cover D
to let's it's a very nice thing to play
and you want to combine protection of
your weaknesses with activity here the
rook on c2 is doing both yeah it's a
reliable defender of the pot but also
able to do things on the C file now
black bet made a mistake he played a
rooty 7 yeah it's I don't know what he
should do group b b8 or something just a
normal move this is this is not good
simply because of offer concrete of a
concrete reply that however was not
played white now play the move rook c8
yeah trading one pair of rooks maybe he
felt under pressure and wanted to get
rid get rid of one of the rooks um in
fact I don't mind trading a rook here
it's not a big issue
like it's not bad for white but he had
an active idea and it is quite
comparable to earlier situations in the
game white is not thinking in terms of
who creed moves you know he was probably
thinking okay I want to trade one rook I
want to make my defense easier but why
do you want to trade here if you can
play rook c6 white can also attack
things rook c6 attacks the Queen and the
text upon the only little thing that you
need to see is that after Queen takes
jack group c8 is winning the house due
to the back rank yeah like has to play
that and it hits it's just an over me
so black cannot reply Queen take C - you
know maybe White was thinking okay I
cannot move the rook because the pawn is
hanging but well he went rook see ahead
so he was aware that there are maybe
some some kind of technical implications
you know it's a case where I'm the
candidate moved principal can help you
before you play out a move you should
really think about what moves come into
consideration at all and if you can
attack a piece of a higher value with
the lower value piece yeah attack a
minor piece with a pawn or take a look
with with the bishop this kind of things
forcing moves they sort of show that you
have an initiative if you can't take
something and force a reply this is what
is really used to get a momentum in a
game and here the move rook c6 has to be
on the list of moves to be checked and
if you start to check the move and see
that okay he cannot take only two well
then that must be a good move the Queen
really where is it's supposed to go if
you start the calculation here you see
that probably maybe queen g4 yeah just
an active move if you play something
passive it it can't be really good so
Queen G
four and now we just take it yeah a pawn
is a pawn and we can now safely tell
black okay
show me what you got and black again he
cannot take on he - yeah the root
position he is very unlucky and let's
say rookie - yeah and that's it yeah
it's really a the worst possible place
for this rook yeah so what basically
could have won upon and it is I have to
say if you look at the line group here
black black is not dead yet yeah he will
he will continue stuff like this this it
shouldn't be underestimated you have
white has a slightly weakened King
position without the Chateau Bishop so
it's not something why you should expect
to win automatically yeah but white of
course has a substantial advantage he
just has won the pawn and now needs to
be precise in defense a good ideas to
start with something like that that
again protects the pawn now he too was
also hanging as challenge already should
get rid of that one let's close the
challenge option here yeah black will
play the Age pawn and try to get counter
play like that but it's so it still as a
pawn yeah so with precise play White has
chances to win this certainly but he
played rook c8 black went back to d8 and
we actually get the rooks traded yeah so
here we see that white um was successful
with his trading idea um but he he for
faded this idea with rooks e6 getting an
advantage now it's not possible anymore
but okay white is not in trouble
hmm the next move is it's very
interesting
in fact because it fits to the to the
general attitude why displaying a bit
too timidly all the time not really
going for active moves he played the
move Queen t1 now which I can only guess
was maybe directed maybe against Queen B
3 that he was concerned that the queen
is is entering I'm not not completely
completely sure there might be some
other idea that I don't that I cannot
guess correctly what was a good move for
ever well there's just one open file in
this position it's a C file and what we
want is we want to invade so a simple
move to to consider here is just Queen
c2 intending to invade here on c7 yeah
activity forward yeah this is this is
how it goes the one who is more active
in a game of chess is very often the one
who wins it yeah it's just the case
initiative activity is crucial and I
just sitting around and shuffling will
very often lead to defeat and here why
not use what you have in this position
the C file Queen c2 gives right a little
bit of hope not to do something it's
probably still about equal if black
plays plays precisely but yeah it is
maybe a little something yeah what is
flex supposed to do maybe he marches the
H point okay we enter here yeah winning
a tempo this is what I mean initiative
yeah we get active pieces can attack
blacks pieces and in the meantime yeah
maybe
get to the pawn here on a6 and so on
it's just active you need to be active
and not just defend weaknesses passively
if you can do this with active moves
yeah
Queen you won and a passive moves and
black now plays h5 that's of course a
good move yeah it's a good multi-purpose
move it makes sure that the the back
rank is not so weak and it uses this
pawn as a battering ram
the king sorry that's just good here
okay it's it's it's difficult now to
play maybe because you just played queen
you wanna but again you should play
Queen see - Quincy - Queen - Queen
season for Queen c6 or Queen c7
activating the Queen white played h4
this is not I mean it's still okay it's
still about equal but it is just passive
you have you can play actively you
should do it this is actually like in 95
percent of the time yeah there are very
very few exceptions where passive
defense or passive play is really the
right one sometimes we come into a
situation where we don't spot an active
defense okay then you just failed in
finding the active defense or active way
to play this sometimes happens I mean
especially with the lack of time I mean
if you play blitz chess I mean on my
games yeah sometimes I get into
positions where make passive moves and
just sit there and I'm kind of home what
a position is that and some of you
sometimes you don't see the active
defense but if you see one you see an
active way to play an active way to
defend or whatever and you see a passive
one really discard the passive one it
will be worse almost all of the time
so here Queen c2 again was the right way
to go after h4 black is getting an
initiative that is really really
somewhat dangerous and a strong move now
very strong move black now play g5 I
have to say that ultimately it should be
still equal but yeah black is taking the
initiative here very important he's
taking over the initiative on the board
and also the psychological one yeah he's
the second now and it's always easier to
attack then defend Jewess g5 he has yeah
he shows that he saw that White's King
position is weakened and he's yeah
getting getting to work immediately
opening this up now it gets difficult I
also assume that um I don't have the
information about the time spent but I
also
suspect that the time was was getting
low getting low him also I mean it is an
anonymous game but the place where the
game was played actually suggests that
this is kind of a quick classical time
control game here like 90 minutes and 30
seconds per move or maybe 60 minutes
with 30 seconds per move so I guess here
there already was some some time
pressure involved right now played the
move Queen d2 which is a good one white
also could take I could have taken and
then aged four that was the idea but the
defense here is really really tricky and
move like Queen f1 for example will
defend but it's not easy to come up with
those ideas yeah it's not a very
intuitive move the ideas too
here I'm sorry of course not to it have
this available and now yeah it's it's a
question what black is going to do we
can do something oops something like
that
yeah this is this is a possible line
white will defend but it it's not a very
natural proceeding and Turkey Queen d2
is actually okay this is a case where he
played an active way to defend yeah
Queen to d5 it's actually nice group d5
Queen takes Queen e2 so white has given
up this pawn money too but the counter
play that he is getting now he gets one
the rooks ehm yeah if difficult to to
realize in a in a practical game also a
case where yeah the computer-aided
analysis is not painting a very accurate
picture if you look at the position and
give it to a computer it will just say
just 0 0 0 equal yeah and the point is
however it is very difficult to find
it's really difficult to find the move
that is obviously not obviously
but obviously the wrong word it's
drawing the computer is really proving
that is green F form it's not a very
intuitive move what is this doing in a
text f7 okay but other than that it
seems like black has a ton of options
but it's not so easy at all
how is he going to proceed the other
idea here is rook c7 attacking attacking
here for example let's say black black
retreats with the Queen to cover this
group c7 yeah and how is some black
defending now if he if you do this then
Queen e4s good yeah setting of the pin
and after the trade black is in a
situation where he will not be able to
defend those three pawns it's a very
concrete calculation of the Queen f4 but
if you compare this to other tactical
concrete situation in the game a very
complex one after Queen f4 black has ton
of moves and sometimes the moves that
are key for wine are not easy to find
after king g6 for example which is using
the king actively a very yeah very
possible move then the move rook g8 is
actually strong threatening Bishop to f8
and those moves are they're not not
super easy to find Queen f4 was the way
to continue but it is very difficult
he played King efore check which is the
more obvious move take sticks and now
now white a no black makes a mistake
which is giving away the advantage that
was yeah granted to him after Queen e4
check he should have played the move
rook d7 now what he played is actually
kind of mysterious but it's probably
also due to time time problems rook d7
is the strongest move here and this is
simply due to this
very basic but very true rule that the
rooks are best behind the passes you
want to support your deep one which is
your your trump card and on d7 the rook
is doing this job perfectly
you know if white is trying to snatch
pawns you're going to push the pawn here
and you're going to get active in in
various ways you can your rookie 7.now
or Luke t4 and black is the one being
active and calling the shots due to the
reduced material white can fight with
some hope but this is definitely better
for black what he did to the black
player here is rookie 5 yeah that's not
really where the look wants to be after
f3 the rook is looking just had a very
safely protected pawn and yeah it was it
wasn't a very successful idea Bishop h6
and now Luke c6
this is this is okay rook e8 however
again yeah getting behind the the passer
what's the easier way to play it and
here white is actually active enough for
draw I wish I could say check energy too
and I know maybe King g6m like has the
Salukis North Korea it's kind of unlucky
replaced okay it can go to e6 yeah but
well it hasn't doesn't have any a big
point there
yeah let's say Bishop e6 to force it to
e6 and Bishop c5 and white will win the
pawn yeah um it continues but what has
what has a draw let's aim it at the end
rook c6 however it's not a mistake it's
just less yeah it's the lesson principle
move you want to fight against your main
enemy which is the D pawn so look at the
aid was saw stronger rupee six
yeah keeping keeping the look King f1
that was that was okay as well Bishop g7
again it's a it's still a draw position
and Bishop g7 yeah and now here white
should have played King e2
yeah just the way to go using the king
as a block Aida and maybe when it
actually comes to the three maybe you
even get an f4 f5 I don't know yeah we
are very glad that we have an active
rupiah on c5 that's a very nice piece
yeah making sure that f5 is not coming
and always keeping pressure yeah some
pressure may be on the pawn and also on
the Queen side which cannot move so
white here has enough for for his porn
in terms of yeah defensive compensation
it is it is enough to defend the active
pieces that White has however in the
game he played the move a4 which is a
tragic error after this this fight as
now bishop f8 was was winning material
so what he is at least losing in
exchange and this is the position we're
losing the exchanges the same thing as
losing the game as the the passes are
just too strong sometimes you can hide
with being an exchange down but that's
not one of those positions because the
pawns are just too strong
yeah he tried f4 bishop takes and well
yeah f5 check was played it doesn't
really make a difference in this
continuation of the game white was a
piece up what was a piece down and
resigned resigned now yeah that was the
first viewer game a game that the viewer
of the channel lost yeah and they say
that you learned from your losses
yeah you can also learn from your wins
it's not it's not very
it's not it's not that you learn from
losses only but this is the game I think
where the white player can draw some
conclusions on let's say if I see this
game and I should give the white player
ideas what to do what to improve about
this game is that he probably this is
just one game one game is very tough to
draw conclusions upon but there are some
cases some stages situations in this
game where white was playing a bit too
passively yeah moves like d3 Bishop T to
Quincy one yeah those moves are
relatively passive moves especially with
white where you want to push but in
general yeah you want to be the one to
to open the position to to go forward
and white was mostly reacting in this
phase of the game after d5 when the
situation opened up white had a
technical chance with ninety five here
and Bishop and four but didn't take it
so the white player seems to be very
often in a state of mind
yeah how to place my pieces where I can
I put them those kind of things instead
of concretely approaching your position
what can i what are the moves that I can
play can i attack something can I use
some disharmony in my opponent's
position so the white player really
should try to play in a more concrete
way of thinking more in terms of yeah it
takes direct ideas then instead of
abstract maneuvers or ideas yeah just
going a little bit back to the basics
also probably do some work on
calculation of lines maybe he saw the
one one or two of those ideas but he
kind of yeah lost lost track a little
bit when he looked at the moves and then
went for something more passive
because it felt more safe to him safe is
very often not good you know it done it
I can only guess at some in some stages
so you know what I would definitely say
the white player should focus is his own
studies here on on concrete play on on
aggressive play good ideas to study
games that feature active aggressive
chess and active aggressive players you
know it's not so easy to do that with
modern games because they are simply on
such a high level that you don't see
many mistakes and at all so on some
older games come to mind for example if
you want to go really old then something
like the world champion Alexander other
kind he was a fantastic dynamic player
and he has won many many straight
forward attacking games even against
good opposition and it wasn't really
they weren't talking Pat says you know
this was already on a level that you can
very much compare with some some modern
play not modern top class play but that
he didn't play against complete amateurs
and those games are instructive where
you can see how to how to punish
somewhat insecure dynamic play and those
chances that are presented to to a
player like here with Bishop III we can
attack this and here basically set up a
double attack those chances have to be
taken this is far more important then
abstract considerations in a game yeah
you want to use those concrete chances
this is where the points are wanted lost
very often you know you can play a ton
of fancy moves if you don't use your
chances you're not going to go in to win
the games yeah this was the first viewer
game on video the first off I hope more
to come well I hope I will definitely
make more of them but it's also of
course about feedback yeah however well
it is received on the channel I have a
tomboy he sent me
many many games so I can basically do
this for weeks if you like yeah I hope
you enjoyed that it was a it was an
interesting game to watch and if you
don't watch the channel see all of the
videos there's a live show coming out
also on Monday the 23rd I should
February 2015
should mention that there's a separate
video on that but if in case you've just
sees this one yeah make sure to tune in
okay well thanks for watching and I'll
be back with more of these I think in a
couple of days
Thanks